Traduttore: Silvia Spolaore Mergaert
Revisore: Cristina Bufi-Pöcksteiner
Buon pomeriggio.
Comincio con una domanda.
Vi siete mai chiesti perché
alcune tecnologie che utilizziamo
sono belle, emozionanti,
ci divertono, ci piace utilizzarle,
e altre invece sono frustranti e fredde?
Immagino che sarà capitato a tutti voi
di dover studiare un intero manuale
per decidere la temperatura
da un termostato di casa, ad esempio.
Il termostato forse è una delle cose
più frustanti che ci sono.
"Voglio caldo e non riesco a farlo."
Eppure questo ci succede ogni giorno.
Allora per provare a capire insieme
che cosa c'è di bello
nell'interazione con le tecnologie,
vi racconto una piccola storia.
Allora immaginate di essere in un negozio,
volete comprare dei biscotti,
la persona che vi sta servendo
prende i biscotti, ve li butta ai piedi,
e i biscotti si rompono
e voi dovete piegarvi per raccoglierli.
Sarebbe possibile accettare
un servizio di questo genere?
Nessuno di noi
accetterebbe, potrebbe accettare
di essere trattato
in questo modo in un negozio.
Eppure questo è quello che ci succede
utilizzando alcune tecnologie.
Pensate ai distributori automatici,
le macchinette, di cui parlavamo
poco fa, prendendo un caffè,
i distributori automatici
di bibite o di merendine.
Vogliamo qualcosa:
dobbiamo inserire le monete,
dobbiamo leggere un codice,
digitare un codice,
vedere se corrisponde
veramente a quello che abbiamo,
spingere un bottone;
la merendina cade
dall'alto in un cassetto buio;
dobbiamo chinarci,
ficcare la mano dentro,
spesso c'è un effetto tagliola,
spesso abbiamo delle cose
in mano e quindi è difficile.
Pensate anche a persone
che hanno problemi,
hanno delle disabilità,
hanno delle difficoltà.
Spesso nei posti pubblici,
questi contenitori sono anche sporchi
e dobbiamo metterci la mano dentro.
La tecnologia non ci tratta con rispetto.
Vogliamo essere rispettati nel nostro modo
di interagire con le macchine.
E questa stessa domanda
è stata posta a degli studenti
del corso di Master in Industrial Design
alla Eindhoven University of Technology.
E hanno provato a immaginare
un altro tipo di distributore automatico.
(Musica) (Video)
Che cosa c'è di bello
in questa interazione?
Di bello c'è che i prodotti
cercano di sedurci.
Si girano, si voltano,
si mostrano quando passiamo.
Di bello c'è che usiamo
un linguaggio naturale, usiamo un gesto,
diciamo: "Io voglio quello."
Non devo leggere un codice,
non devo inserire un numero,
non devo fare nulla di tutto questo,
perché questo è il modo
in cui ci relazioniamo
nella vita di tutti i giorni.
Di bello c'è l'estetica dell'interazione.
La macchina si apre
in un modo molto bello e si offre,
offre il prodotto alla persona.
Ecco, questo è il bello
che c'è nell'interazione.
E guardate che ogni giorno
utilizziamo tecnologie
che ci promettono
un'interazione molto "engaging",
un'interazione che ci coinvolge.
Possiamo spostare oggetti, cliccare,
possiamo muovere delle icone.
Ma che cosa tocchiamo veramente,
quando tocchiamo un touch screen?
Tocchiamo degli oggetti
che non hanno qualità.
Non sentiamo l'attrito, non sentiamo
la materia di cui sono composti,
non hanno una texture.
Quante volte vediamo persone
sul cellulare che dicono: "Dai, sbrigati!"
perché magari vogliono fare una foto
e l'oggetto si sta muovendo.
La macchina non risponde,
non riconosce la nostra espressività.
Eppure noi siamo molto espressivi
nella vita di tutti i giorni.
Non funzioniamo
con un'interazione di tipo on/off.
Non aspettiamo che qualcuno
ci chieda una cosa per rispondere.
Le tecnologie oggi non funzionano così.
E allora come funziona l'interazione,
nella vita di tutti i giorni?
Ci sono due aspetti che sono importanti,
nell'interazione con gli oggetti.
Uno è la continuità nell'interazione:
noi interagiamo continuamente.
Io vi sto guardando
e adatto il mio modo di parlare
al modo in cui voi mi state guardando.
Ed è continuo; è uno scambio continuo.
E l'altro punto importante
è che l'interazione è espressiva.
Guardate questa arancia:
il modo in cui io riesco a spremerla
dipende dalla grandezza della mia mano,
dalla forza che esercito,
da ciò che voglio avere.
Quindi esprimo un'intenzione di ottenere
un certo feedback dalla macchina.
E là ci siamo chiesti:
"Ma è possibile strizzarla,
un'interfaccia?"
Apparentemente sì; abbiamo sviluppato
un progetto molto interessante.
Questa è una cover per tablet
che abbiamo modellato in 3D,
abbiamo stampato in 3D in gomma morbida.
Come vedete abbiamo
inserito dell'elettronica:
dei sensori di pressione,
degli attuatori, sono dei piccoli motori,
che danno una restituzione,
un feedback tattile quando si strizza,
e abbiamo sviluppato
una piccola applicazione
per fare lo zoom, quando
facciamo delle fotografie.
Questo è come funziona.
(Musica) (Video)
Bene! Questo tipo di interazione,
volevamo ovviamente provarla.
E l'abbiamo comparata con le altre
modalità che sono native dei tablet.
Quella che vedete
sulla sinistra è lo slide,
quando dobbiamo muovere
quella rotellina per fare lo zoom,
ma anche con il pinch.
L'abbiamo provata in Piazza del Campo.
Abbiamo coinvolto
in questo studio 70 persone
prese a caso tra chiunque
passasse in Piazza del Campo.
Abbiamo dato la cover,
abbiamo chiesto di fare una foto
dell'orologio della Torre del Mangia.
E abbiamo chiesto loro
di compilare un questionario.
E abbiamo visto che, al di là
di una piccola iniziale incertezza
per provare questo sistema, in realtà
le persone apprezzavano moltissimo
le qualità edoniche di questo prodotto
e quindi si divertivano, lo sentivano,
lo provavano; provavano a fare delle foto
diverse da come le fanno normalmente.
Questo è un sistema che lavora,
come diceva Domenico Pratichizzo prima:
"Lavoriamo sulle mani e sul modo
di interagire con le mani e con le dita".
Ma questo concetto di espressività
lo possiamo estendere a tutto il corpo.
Sempre nel mio laboratorio
abbiamo sviluppato una serie
di strumenti musicali in cartone.
Lavoriamo moltissimo
con materiale riciclato,
perché vogliamo sviluppare prototipi,
prima di andare poi a fare
uno sviluppo più importante,
proprio per rendere
espressivo il corpo e poter suonare.
Questi sono due strumenti.
Questa è una console da DJ.
(Musica) (Video)
Ecco; e per serendipity,
come qualcuno diceva questa mattina,
l'abbiamo provata con dei bambini,
che si sono divertiti da morire
a suonare con questi strumenti,
e l'abbiamo provata, per caso,
con dei bambini con dislessia.
E li abbiamo fatti rappare
e abbiamo chiesto loro di scrivere
una piccola strofa di una canzone.
Abbiamo chiesto loro di rappare
e di suonare con questi strumenti
che si indossano.
E abbiamo visto che facevano
molti meno errori,
sia nella lettura che nella produzione
del parlato, del cantato in questo caso.
Il valore della prototipazione
dell'espressione del corpo,
della tangibilità di certe tecnologie
è davvero interessante.
L'ultimo caso che voglio farvi vedere
ed è un po' un caso storico
per il mio laboratorio, un lavoro...
Abbiamo una collaborazione
da ormai 15 anni
con l'Università di Tsukuba in Giappone
e abbiamo importato
dall'Italia questo robot.
Si chiama Paro ed è un cucciolo
di foca, è una foca robotica,
che utilizziamo con persone
con vari tipi di disabilità,
la disabilità motoria e cognitiva.
Ma più recentemente
abbiamo fatto molti studi
con anziani con demenza.
Le signore che vedete in questo video
appunto sono persone che hanno
livelli diversi di demenza.
Abbiamo lavorato anche con persone
con Alzheimer in fase aggressiva.
La foca lavora su un concetto
molto interessante
che è quello del prendersi
cura, del coccolarsi.
Quando si abbraccia fa le fusa,
sbatte gli occhi, la possiamo addestrare.
Ha un algoritmo di apprendimento,
per cui impara a riconoscere, a sentire
la voce, a voltarsi ad alcuni richiami.
È chiaramente ispirata, come potete
immaginare, alla pet therapy.
Ma la cosa importante qui
è che con le tecnologie possiamo stabilire
anche un legame di tipo emotivo,
un coinvolgimento di tipo emotivo.
Vedere queste signore,
che normalmente sono isolate, non fanno
molto durante il giorno, non parlano,
vederle sorridere, scambiarsi,
toccarsi, recitare memorie del passato.
Loro sanno esattamente
che hanno tra le mani una macchina,
perché glielo diciamo subito,
appena cominciamo a lavorare con loro,
ma non gliene importa assolutamente nulla.
Il legame affettivo, la presa in carico,
la cura, sono fondamentali.
Questo breve excursus di progetti
è per dire che possiamo progettare
pensando all'essere umano,
metterlo al centro
della nostra attività di progettazione,
pensarci come a persone con un corpo,
un'espressività, con un'intenzionalità.
E quindi produrre tecnologie
che vanno al di là dell'aspetto funzionale
del risolvere un problema,
ma lavorare anche facendo leva su altre
caratteristiche dell'essere umano.
Concludo dicendo che tutti questi lavori
sono possibili grazie
a un gruppo di ricercatori,
con cui io ho la fortuna di lavorare,
del Laboratorio di Robotica
e Tecnologie per l'Apprendimento
dell'Università di Siena
e del Fab Lab del Santa Chiara,
dove siamo ospitati.
È un gruppo di ragazzi giovani,
motivati, preparati, molto collaborativi
che io ringrazio; e ringrazio voi
per la vostra attenzione.
(Applausi)